the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
8 video as you can see by the title of
the video today I will be talking about
the official photos HBO released a
little bit ago unfortunately we did not
get the season 8 trailer during the
Superbowl like I know we had all hoped
but for now I guess we will just have to
settle with the 14 new photos before we
get started I do want to remind everyone
about the new giveaway just in case some
of you did not see my last video I am
currently giving away the complete a
Song of Ice and Fire book collection as
of right now there are 5 books in the
collection and if you would like to
enter for your chance to win there will
be a link down below just click on that
link and follow those instructions good
luck everyone now let's begin
like I said HBO did release 14 new
photos that were taken during the
filming of the final season now I will
say these photos do not reveal a whole
lot of new information but let's take a
look at them anyway and discuss each one
let's try to have some fun and do some
crazy speculating in the very first
photo we can see Arya Stark and it does
appear as if she's wearing the same
outfit that she had on during season 7
now you would think by this point in the
season it should be very very cold at
Winterfell
not only because winter is here but also
because the night king is on his way
there should be sub-zero temperatures in
the north but Arya is not wearing any
heavy furs in that photo if you do look
behind her you can't really tell where
Arya is in the photo they could all be
wearing northern attire as well but that
doesn't mean they have to be in
Winterfell
or maybe it's just not as cold as we
think and I'm also wondering what Arya
is looking at to me it does look like
she's looking up at something high off
of the ground maybe she's looking at one
of the dragons or if she is in the south
maybe she's looking up at the red key as
we all know Jon and Daenerys will be
arriving with the Dragons in the first
episode of the season but at some point
they will also have to travel
back down to King's Landing to face off
against Cersei Lannister so it's hard to
say what aria is up to in the photo but
the fact that it doesn't look to be very
cold in the photo does make me curious
about her location but let's move on to
the next photo in the next photo we can
see bran stark sitting in his chair and
what appears to be his bedroom it does
look like he's wearing the same heavy
fur coat from last season and I do want
to say it seems like bran has a very
serious look on his face at the moment
I'm guessing that something just
happened maybe he is left with a tough
decision because of something he knows
or something he saw inside of the
weirwood net whatever it is it seems
like he is contemplating what he will do
next I'm thinking that this could be
right before bran has to pull John to
the side to tell him about his parents
or maybe it has something to do with the
night king it's really hard to say just
by looking at his face but my guess is
this is during an interesting scene
which is why HBO decided to release the
photo regardless of the situation at
least brain does appear to be cozy by
the fire in his home in the next photo
we can see brain of ptarth and it looks
like she is also wearing the same heavy
fur from last season as well if you look
closely behind her you can see that
those are the unsullied men standing
right behind her so this has to be taken
after Daenerys and her men have arrived
in what their fell with John and company
I'm assuming they are inside of the
castle at this point most likely in the
main dining hall of Winterfell they
could be holding a meeting inside now
that John and Daenerys have arrived or
this could be shortly after Jaime
Lannister arrives Brienne does not look
exactly pleased in the photo so I'm
guessing it is during a more serious
scene she could be worried about the
Narus being there with the foreign army
or like I said Jaime could be there and
maybe this is during his questioning
about some of his previous crimes
whatever it is I would bet that almost
everyone is in attendance during the
scene since we can see the unsullied
standing right behind her now let's move
on to the next photo here we can see the
lovely Queen Cersei Lannister as she is
sitting on the Iron Throne
I would like to guess that this was also
taken during a very tense scene not only
because the look on Circe's face but
mainly because of the look in her eyes
we all know that look very well it also
looks like her eyes are a bit
I see so I'm gonna guess that Circe just
received some bad news now what that bad
news is can be anyone's guess she could
have learned that Jamie made it to
Winterfell
or maybe Jon and Daenerys are right
outside of the city gates with their
army or maybe something has happened
with Iran and/or the golden company
whatever it is
Cersei does not look very happy now of
course I am just taking some wild
guesses here because like I said there
isn't really much to go on in the photos
since most of them are close-ups of
individual characters we really can't
see what is happening in the background
but as I'm looking at the photo my
initial thought is Cersei does not like
whatever she is hearing in that scene
but let me know what you think
the very next photo is also of Cersei
Lannister and in fact this could have
been taken during the same scene I don't
know why but I just get the sense that
Cersei is feeling a bit defeated in
those images dare I say that these could
even be Circe's final moments in the
show now I know that is a bold
prediction based on absolutely nothing
but if I'm being honest that is the vibe
I'm getting now in the next photo it's a
complete opposite of Circe's reaction
here we can see Daenerys Targaryen and
she looks very happy not just happy but
she also looks as beautiful as ever it
looks like she's wearing a new outfit as
well it does look like the same colors
as she wore last year but this one
appears to be slightly different now
some of you might be asking why would
Daenerys be so happy in that scene one
of her dragons are dead and the my king
is coming their way as he is riding on
that dead dragon what could she possibly
be so happy about well maybe just maybe
she found out she is pregnant by John or
maybe that was already revealed and John
just said that he wants to get married
that way the child isn't born a bastard
obviously I have no idea right now but
that would be my guess the last couple
times I saw Daenerys smile like that was
when John Snow was around or when she
reunited with Jorah Mormont since she
already reunited with Jorah I would like
to think that smile has something to do
with John but let me know what you think
alright now in the next photo we can see
sir Davos Seaworth and once again we can
see the unsullied standing right in the
back my guess is this was taken during
the same scene with Brienne of Tarth
they appear to be inside of the castle
most likely in that main dining hall
where they hold their meetings now I do
doubt that that look would I have
anything to do with Daenerys since Davis
has already spent a significant amount
of time with Danny and they did seem to
get along just fine
like I said earlier this scene could
have something to do with Jaime
Lannister's arrival or maybe they are
holding a meeting about the upcoming
battle against the knight Cain they will
certainly need to start making their
plans of attack very soon weapons need
to be made the castle needs to be fitted
for offensive and defensive weapons so I
imagine they will need to discuss all
these plans besides that I'm not too
sure what they could be doing during
that meeting in the next photo we can
see Sir Jaime Lannister and he does have
a smile on his face but don't let that
smile fool you because I have a
prediction for this photo as well call
me crazy but it almost looks like Jaime
is a prisoner in that photo that was the
very first thought that came to my mind
when I saw the photo even though he does
have a smile on his face the room he is
in is very dark and it makes me wonder
if the Starks have locked Jaime up until
they can figure out what they're gonna
do with them Jaime's appearance has
obviously changed a little bit since we
last saw him we know he was travelling
by horse so it probably took him several
weeks just to make it to Winterfell not
only has his facial hair grown out but
he is wearing some armor now as well and
I don't recall him wearing that when he
left King's Landing but I could be wrong
you know what else Jaime could be doing
in that very dark room he could be
letting any mere Tolley out of the cells
at the twins now I know that I could be
way off on that but I just get the
feeling that Jaime is sitting in some
sort of dungeon or cell if he is in
Winterfell in that scene then I would
imagine that this is shortly after they
questioned him about Cersei and maybe
what he had even done to brand the smile
could be because Tyrion or Brienne are
visiting him in that room but let me
know what your initial thoughts were
next we can see Jon Snow and Daenerys
Targaryen as they are looking off into
the distance at something they are
standing next to a big hill and it looks
like there is some water running along
the side of that hill I don't think they
are in Winterfell during that scene but
it does look like they are somewhere in
the north although now that winter is
here and it should be snowing everywhere
they could be just about anywhere
it's too hard to say what they are
actually looking at but they don't
appear to be scared or worried in that
photo
I suppose this could be them and
arriving at Winterfell and Daenerys is
looking at the castle in the distance
for the first time but I honestly feel
like they are somewhere else
that water running alongside the hill
does make me curious but your guess is
as good as mine the next photo shows Jon
Snow and he appears to be standing
inside of the courtyard at Winterfell I
would guess that this is shortly after
they arrive we have already seen some
teasers of Jon Snow and Daenerys
meaningless Sansa so I would say it was
taken during that scene all right now
the next photo is interesting to me
because I don't think this is in
Winterfell either we can see that same
wall Tarly is standing inside of a
castle somewhere but it doesn't look
like the inside of Winterfell to me I
did go back and look at some of the
scenes in Winterfell during season seven
and I did not notice any of those types
of torches hanging on the walls I'm
honestly wondering if Sam could have
went back to horn Hill during the photo
maybe this is taken at the very end of
the season after all the fighting is
done Samwell Tarly technically would be
the lord of horn Hill now that his
father and brother are both dead now Sam
is still wearing the clothes from the
Nights Watch but I don't think he'll be
going back to Castle black anytime soon
now that the wall was down and there are
no other threats north of the wall I
don't really see a purpose for the
Nights Watch unless the White Walkers
would run back to the north again like
they did during the first long night
my guess is Sam is not in Winterfell
during that photo I'm gonna say it's at
the end of the season when Sam goes back
home with Gilly and little Sam but that
might not be the correct answer either
here we can see songs of stark and it
appears as if her resting [ __ ] is
back in action there isn't really much
else I can add that I haven't already
said because I think it was taken during
the same scene I mentioned earlier we
can't see bringing of Tarth or Davos and
the photo isanzo but I would bet it's
during that same scene in the next photo
we have Tyrion Lannister and this one
was definitely taken in Winterfell this
was where Sansa and Littlefinger stood
last season as they were watching Arya
and Brienne practice down below in the
yard
it looks like terian is wearing a new
outfit in the photo and he looks pretty
damn good if I do say so myself
now he doesn't look to be very happy in
the photo and it also looks like he is
looking at someone else who or what
tyrion is looking at is anyone's guess I
really don't have too many initial
thoughts about the photo without talking
about some of the spoilers which I do
not want to get into in the video let's
just go to the next photo last but not
least we have Lord Varys it looks like
he has a new addition to his outfit from
season 7 and it also looks like he is on
Winterfell walking around the courtyard
I did not really take away much from
that photo either he's probably looking
at someone as well but your guess is as
good as mine if you're wondering what
Varys will be up to next season then I
highly recommend you go and watch my
Theory video about Varys because that
one I do feel really confident about I
will add that link down below with the
giveaway link as well anyways let me
know what you thought about all of the
new photos were you thinking what I was
thinking or did you have some other
ideas in mind these were just my initial
thoughts when I first saw the photos but
I'm sure I will come up with some more
stuff after I do have some time to
process the images anyways I want to
thank all of you who stopped by to watch
the video I really appreciate that and I
also want to thank everyone on patreon
for supporting the channel have a great
day
I'll see you soon bye
you
[Music]
you
[Music]